[Musique]
bon moi je l' ai vécu plus comme une
anxiété
au niveau financier d'abord
c'est ce que je veux retrouver mon
travail est ce que je devrais retourner
à l'école changer de branche
qu'est ce que je vais devenir
je me sentais toujours résistante mais à
la fin moi aussi j'ai fini par
développer les symptômes de stress
anxiété insomnie beaucoup plus
l'incertitude envers le système
on pensait jamais que huit mois plus
tard on en serait là maintenant
je m'appelle elisa boudreau j'ai 47ans
et je suis musicienne classique à la
pige
[Musique]
le 12 mars dernier j'étais en route pour
leur question phonique de drummondville
en route pour la générali le concert on
a eu un appel pour nous dire rendez vous
ont fait la générale mais il y aura pas
le concert le soir
donc ça a commencé comme ça puis ensuite
tout déboule et tout a été annulé
donc là ça s'est arrêté un peu pour vous
à ce moment-là ça c'est tout arrêter moi
je suis quand même est habitué à
l'insécurité et en tant que pigiste de
jamais savoir très en avance mais quand
même c'était ce malaise différent c'est
comme une angoisse de on a publié l'on
peut même pu avoir les mêmes repères que
d'habitude
je pense que pour moi plusieurs
premières masses et de raccrocher mais
elle c'est de laisser de côté un travail
que j'adorais vraiment je m'appelle marc
antoine roussel j'ai 30 ans et j'étais
directeur de vol pour une compagnie
aérienne
c'est surtout je pense qu'on fait aussi
ce métier là parce qu'on adore être en
contact avec différentes personnes on
aime le contact humain depuis avoir ça
aussi c'est définitivement quelque chose
qui qui nous manque beaucoup
l'aviation toujours été ma passion donc
de pouvoir faire ce travail là elle
s'était retirée c'était l'amour de ma
vie si je peux redevenir directeur
d'abord ce que je vais être capable
d'aimer un autre travail autant que
celui là c'est tellement difficile
c'était trop de charges trop de missions
trop de fatick les personnes et qui
parfois crier puis plus ré je m'appelle
une usma boys in blue
j'ai 35 ans je travaille comme anthony
et aux soins intensifs racontez-moi un
peu comment vous vous êtes retrouvé dans
un siège et celle d'hier face à une
inclusion je te là pour aider en fait
moi je fais comme je travaillais au
cordeau je lui ai cinq six étages
presque 300 personnes moi j'étais
responsable mais j'avais dit au xie puis
des préposés mais les étudier pour la
moitié était pas là le proposait la
moitié était pas là puis le responsable
est pas quoi faire et dans la résidence
performation premièrement problème
principal deuxièmement politiquement
donc tous les moyens pour combattre
covit existe pas c'était comme au caire
mais les soldats qui savent pas comment
utiliser les armes à feu qui les armes
at on n'existe pas
ce qui était difficile je crois aussi
c'est que on s'est senti un peu exclu
dans la société dans l'opinion publique
c'est comme si les gens disent c'est
juste du divertissement
on est les premiers à fermer les
derniers ouvrir 100 passagers on sert
plus à rien
on est des avions vides il y a des gens
qui disent ok les personnes auraient dû
parler parler moi j'ai parlé des
premières minutes j'ai appelé plusieurs
organismes c'est même la police or des
infirmiers puis toute personne voulait
bouger puis on est au courant vous ça
vous a affecté personnellement quand je
rentrais chez moi je regardais facebook
on était condamné par la société comme
une personnalité travers deux dans le
sas avait dans la télé tulmont par les
enquêtes personnel pour passer un faux
pas est ce qu a eu des moments où
c'était plus sombre pour vous la nuit
oui au moment où avec l'insomnie tous
les qui vient je pense que découler
beaucoup de choses c'est de la
frustration c'était beaucoup de
questionnements aussi de pas savoir ce
qui va se passer demain ça ça marche pas
avec ma façon de penser parce que vous
avez cessé de jouer pendant un certain
temps
oui je sais c'est peut-être trois
semaines j'ai du ray au printemps pour
une musicienne quand même arrêté de
jouer quelques shows de vol puis aussi
de c'est la première fois que j'avais
aucune pièce à apprendre qui m'attendait
ya toujours quelque chose après la
hauteur qui prochaine pièce apprend des
fourneaux plusieurs en même temps
et pendant là pour les nuits qu'est ce
qui vous a aidé à passer à travers
premièrement la famille j'avais la
chance d'avoir des parents qui étaient
très proches et j'avais mon meilleur ami
aussi qu'ils étaient là j'avais mon
chien c'est un peu drôle à dire mais ça
fait une présence ou est définitivement
que ça me donne une raison de sortir
dehors c'était rendu qu'on faisait quoi
4 marche par jour
la déprime c'était plus difficultés à
fonctionner dans ma journée est très
très tributaires de la météo aussi car
il faisait beau j'étais de bonne humeur
puis dès qu'il faisait pas beau on
dirait que j'avais besoin de soleil
c'était plus montagneuses des journées
ça allait bien des journées moins bien
premier revers pour moi cette
discrimination n'est pas ce que c'était
les mêmes qui ont bâti la société ont
bâti des hôpitaux vous savez donc
arrêter les aînés qui ont pillé tout ça
pour peut-être avoir un petit peu de
dignité dans les derniers jours de leur
vie
mais à la fin on a bien redonner l'image
pandémie dans ma tête c'est une madame
âgées mais c'est le bal puis décédé
depuis 24 heures dans sa chambre sa vie
tout seul c'est pénible dans ma vie
personnelle j'ai déjà fait face à six
puis tout ça je connais un petit peu
c'était comme ça pour moi puis votre
espoir c'est quoi maintenant la vente
ont dévoilé ce soir c'est à tous les
jours et j'espère ouvrir mes emails
depuis bord comme quoi ça s'est passé et
puis on est prêt à retourner les parents
dit là bas non physiquement pour falloir
apprendre à vivre avec pour certaines
tâches pas versée ils vont changer les
choses
après qu vite quand ils vont avoir assez
de temps pour régler le problème qu'on
vous faut une fois pour toujours j'ai
retrouvé en fait là
la nécessité pour la société d'avoir la
muse et puis le l'amour aussi que le
besoin que j'ai d'enfer le besoin la
partager je pense puis aussi d'en
écouter plus je me suis aperçu de
l'importance la musique de l'utilité
dans ma vie
[Musique]